hey guys other podcast sorry it's so
late but it's here I'm knee-deep in
production right now so I apologize but
another one next week I got al Jackson
and Omar Dorsey coming up the week after
that really fantastic podcast I'm feel
like I'm really hitting my stride I want
to thank everyone for watching trip flip
Tuesday nights on travel channel at 8pm
Tuesday nights this week coming up is
what I would argue to say my opus it is
Vietnam it is an hour special these
people we take we're not stereotypical
people we take on a trip flip the the
crash is not a stereotypical crash it is
it is the product products thing I've
ever done because I fought really hard
for these kids and for one of the
activities we do and I promise you what
I tell you you will watch this and you
will everyone will be talking about this
it is called ear picking we go to
Vietnam it's the best episode I think
that we've ever done so check out trip
flip tuesday night at 8pm and also
everyone thank you for all the kind
words about the fall everyone was very
nice i saw the trip flipped tanzania
episode the trip flip North Carolina
episode everyone mentioned my fall and I
thought that was very sweet of everyone
obviously I've had problems with my back
and that brings us to what I really want
to talk to you about my back has been
absolutely killing me we bought a bed a
really expensive bed really expensive in
like a store so I didn't realize this
but you're paying for the guys wages who
works in a store you're paying for the
overhead of having the store you're
paying for the taxes and the rent on the
store so that's why this Pet mattress
was so [ __ ] expensive because it
sucked it was hard as a rock and it
sucked and quite honestly I've gotten
used to a hotel beds I've gotten used to
like I always say the four seasons
recently and their bed was like gold and
I was like how do I get one of these
beds cut to Tom
segura Tom Segura is having the same
problem I think it's both because we're
both fat he introduces me this mattress
called sattva [ __ ] next level I'm
telling you as a man who has fallen off
a waterfall had back problems this is
the best mattress out there and it's an
online retailer so you don't have to pay
for the mark-up of the guy who is in the
weird suit with the tie that has the
doughnut stain on it and he's trying to
sell you a mattress and he's like come
on and then you're laying down this is
they've got a 75 day trial so get this
mattress go to smart bed calm I think
it's smart bed calm pretty sure it's
smart pet calm is it smart bed calm I'm
almost certain it's smart but smarter
bed calm go to smarter bed calm and get
yourself a sattva mattress I'm telling
you in the price point that you would
buy in the store they are already half
is cheap because they're not on a store
their online they don't just drop it to
you in a box their front door they
install it they take away the shitty
mattress you've been sleeping on here's
my theory all mattresses everybody I'm
being dead serious when I say this you
spend half of your life laying down that
is the thing that will cause your
longevity as your sleep your sleep is
directly related to your longevity why
wouldn't you spend it's because people
don't see it that's what you think you
spend fifty thousand dollars in a car
that you never drive but maybe an hour a
day and then all of a sudden you're
dropping what a hundred bucks on a
mattress five hundred bucks on a
mattress get this bed satva beds the
brand is saat VA but just to make it
easier their website smarter bed calm
smarter bed calm tell them you heard
about us on the podcast at the very end
of the checkout select podcast this is
I'm telling you a grassroots campaign by
one Tom Segura and I don't know if I'm
supposed to say that or not but he's
having sleep problems we all have sleep
problems because we all travel so much
that we don't get used to one bed Tom
finds his bed he hooks us up all with
these beds and now we love these beds so
go to smarter bed
sattva mattress is kind of hard to spell
but it's a sa a TV a mattress ma TT ress
calm and check podcast right when you
check out okay go to smarter bed comm
check podcast at checkout this helps
track the purchases that were made
through Tom and me and ari and all the
guys that Tom's hooked up with these
mattresses and you know quite honestly
good products if I if I find something
cool I send it to you you know that i
just snorted it's not down my nose I
tell you to try my first set of blood
pressure medicine because my first set
of blood pressure medicine was better
than what i'm using now quite honestly I
like those shirts pilot and captain I
hooked you guys up a pilot and captain
with the discount I still wear those
shirts I wear them on TV I like welcome
skateboards I like nike sb's I tell you
the stuff I like the shoes they're
really comfortable have you spent a lot
of time in your feet can I see nike sb's
and get inserts I get inserts with all
my shoes this is all on by the way I'm
I'm marketing to people that are exactly
like me because we all have the exact
same problems we're all overweight we
all have a hard time sleeping we mean I
me and all my friends travel I'm on my
feet so sattva beds check them out at
smarter bed calm tell them that we sent
you by clicking podcast all right
today's episode after that long-winded
ad and I'm sorry I'm just passionate
about sleep I have been ever since I was
a child today's guest from the Chappelle
show the co-creator of the Chappelle
show the director of the goods stand-up
comedian one of the funniest guys
working today no question about it and
this is a beautiful conversation Neal
Brennan
what's the thing your alarm goes off
yeah in order to turn it off oh shut the
[ __ ] off Rick you got Mike wait HAP's
getting small caps non caps numbers so
um yeah did they hear what we're did
they know you tell us a night um there i
just downloaded an app two weeks ago I
don't have a hard time like Anna my fear
that I'm gonna have more time waking up
yeah um so there's an app called I can't
wake up where the alarm goes off on your
phone and in order to turn it off you
have to type in a code that they put on
the screen and it's like a 25 character
code and it takes 55 seconds if you're
doing it well it takes 55 seconds but
you [ __ ] up like I i'm so tired that
point like i'll [ __ ] up and real and it
says like you made a mistake go back and
i will made it like ten characters
before but the [ __ ] it's really really
great yeah it's really good i canno you
want to know really really great you you
don't need to work out do ya work out ok
yeah but you're [ __ ] naturally skinny
yeah but that's not from like you know I
don't eat a ton and I exercise
vegetarian yeah be vegan mm-hmm wow I
couldn't do that I would be talking la
it's not hard I bet you give grew that
vegan restaurants here's the best
workout app I've ever found it's called
um trail mix ok I think it's called
trail mix I'll pull it up to make sure
what it does is it changes whatever song
you want to the beats per minute that
you're jogging it's cool so you take
your song and it's one of my favorite
apps ever and I just it just turns out
like I love like there's certain songs
that like that you also you just it's
your pacing yeah so what it does is it
metronomes your steps so all whatever
you're doing that's where the songs just
so dead
it to it is it are all the songs on your
phone or it's all on your phone it takes
all the folk songs on your phone Trail
Mix pro run with music and it's and you
basically it takes all your songs and
then speeds them up and then what you
can also do is you can just take them
cuz it's got a yeah counted up to 170
beats per minute you just take your song
to just speed them up to whatever you
want oh wow so like I take like girl
talk I love girl talk yeah if you ever
listen girl work I listen to girl talk
and then I'll just although I gotta say
girl talk it gets old quickly yeah like
it's like all right man I guess I have
that you're mixing [ __ ] up I get it but
after a while it's like all right this
is too chaotic see I always had that
problem you're let you like hip-hop
right I always had the problem diamond m
I think he's a great yeah her cyst but
like that that song remember the song uh
this vomit on his shirt from last Monday
yeah I could never get into that so I
couldn't play that song in if you don't
like lose yourself that's like his most
sort of logical I love the song right I
couldn't connect the song in a moment of
my own victory god I don't like say I
it's more about anticipation all right
yeah it will say like Sam like you don't
listen to before you go on stage like
never yeah it feels it feels Hollow it
feels sugary it doesn't feel like this
is what it actually feels like does it
form right it doesn't and it but it
didn't ever connected like like if I
listen to like ti uh you remember what
you did this week remember you don't
know me yeah I hear that I connect with
those words and I can feel in the moment
and I can get lost in the music I could
never get lost in Eminem's music ever I
always felt like there was too many um
too many things going on in it that I
never felt the heartfelt connection with
his music and my moment he's well the
thing about Eminem is his music is
inherently defensive what means it
because he's so defensive about being
white yeah in hip-hop yeah any such an
angry guy naturally yeah that it's all
anger and like [ __ ] you like Eminem's
one of those guys like if it's songs
were person you'd be like hey I mean
[ __ ] you and you're like I man I just
want to listen to your music yeah um I
just love music and whatever now having
I met him and he's a good dude yeah yeah
is he distant and quiet and doesn't he's
a weird guy it was like a weird like I'd
say he probably has some sort of like
Asperger's he you know he's good at one
thing yeah he's really good at rapping
yeah he so he's a really is a great
rapper he's an amazing but he is like
everyone you know he's got like he's
probably on the spectrum as they say
like he's like a weird the thing that
people don't know about Eminem and it
was in this documentary called how does
how to be a drug dealer yeah he probably
four or five years ago had a horrible
drug problem yeah I knew that but like
to the point where he said he couldn't
speak he lost he when he quit or no when
he quit doing them he said when he
kicked he stayed up for 48 hours
straight just stared at a television and
then he couldn't walk and couldn't speak
really had to go to rehab like he had to
go to like physical rehab and a speech
therapy holy [ __ ] yeah it's in that
documentary it's amazing and no one
really talked it's like [ __ ] crazy
that's insane yeah he is one of those
guys that I discovered late meaning like
everyone knew he was and I still didn't
get the genius of him and then I did and
I want oh [ __ ] he's really good yeah but
I was you know I was I was groomed on
southern hip hop you know like so I
would like what connects with me is more
like the something you imagine feeling
like a horse stable what's that I'm
picturing you in like a horse stable and
someone like brushing you yeah for me
listen to this town with with an old
Outkast CD but like it's interesting to
me that that hip-hop is made for
different cultures in different areas
based on how people in take their music
yeah so like I'm I'm a car listening hip
hop guy i'm not a headset listening New
York hip hop guy mm-hmm like jay-z JC's
gray in a car but you know some of his
[ __ ] I'm same [ __ ] with them and that
maybe that's what it is maybe what I'm
talking about is cultural like
I don't get I don't like your phone
hip-hop I mean that's I don't know if
anyone would ever categorize that way
yeah your phone hip-hop were not hear
from him but like I never heard that
category there's definitely like there's
a lot of miami music that is not meant
for headsets at all uh yeah it's uh well
yeah but you cannot yet maybe for final
trick daddy belongs in a [ __ ] it's
made for outdoor [ __ ] yeah if never
liked [ __ ] on a dock I like on a
shitty motorboat did you had it was what
was the when did you get into hip-hop
[ __ ] man uh Public Enemy 1988 I'm 41
okay your might yeah uh so yeah like 19
I remember hearing public enemy at a
basketball game at like my high school
basketball game and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this and then I was like oh this
is so this is the best and because I
wasn't into run DMC in the Beastie Boys
for like cuz I people don't really
remember or know how entrenched classic
rock used to be yeah like that was all
that you've had like if you're a white
person and like the suburbs it's classic
rock that was all there was oh yeah um
so like I remember starting to listen to
hip-hop and one of my brother's going
like what the hell is that [ __ ] you know
like yeah like completely just a bad
call historically and I was like no this
is gabe's like Marvin berry it's like
looking back the future so uh so yes
that was when I got into it and then
like you know I've been I wrote for the
source at one point like I like all this
guy's did Chappelle and I met probably
all of them by this point it was uh i
don't know i don't like talk I would
never want to talk to you about
schapelle at all why but there's cuz i
don't know i don't like doing that i
don't know i might as well my brain I
mean like I figure all I figure every
time you do anything to promote your
hour everyone wants to talk about that
uh well they people want to talk that no
one has an interesting point of view on
it I mean I don't mind taught it's like
it's not looking great thing that I did
and I'm proud
all I'd want to talk about was the end
no no no no not at all I don't even care
about that yeah um the item met him I
met him recently at the Dayton funny
bone and I was I was impressed at how
human he was I think he'd been put on a
pedal pedestal so much by comics and my
fans yeah that I was impressed with just
exactly they I forgot he's like a comic
too and he was working on material also
and he was like as unsure of his new
[ __ ] as I am my new [ __ ] yeah and I was
like oh I forgot about that I was like
and you're my age like this okay yeah so
but uh no my favorite moment of that
show ever was always the music oh that's
cool yeah music was always done so well
some of it was like really great oh
really like some of the ways we did [ __ ]
was like that was based on me and chip
out like he was friends with most def
and those guys we hang out most defs
most have a trap in the car I was like
oh this is very cool and I knew the pc
boys and they used to like they had a
video that was like they did it in a
basement on sort of just like shitty
cameras and uh and I was like that seems
like the best way in fact that James
Corden thing that he did with justin
bieber the other night like were they
sang in the cards like oh this is just
the thing we did yeah 12 years ago it
was extremely original yeah like all the
way you guys presented music was
extremely original yeah it made that
show feel like it's not just a sketch
show I think at Comedy Central has tried
to replicate it a number of times and I
think they've always missed on the fact
that that show is more about culture yet
it was sketch well yeah it for sure I
mean I think that I Comedy Central
didn't like the music parts really mean
it's a pain in the ass you gotta clear
[ __ ] oh yeah it's a shame the places he
gotta click like on the DVD like John
Mayer did a sketch on the DVD and in
order to or on the show and then in
order to have him on this on the DVD we
would have had to pay Sony like 50 grand
just to have them like just because they
own them just [ __ ] like that where it's
like oh like this is such a pain in the
ass even clearing music was paying them
my favorite music clearance story was we
wanted and outcasts
long we wanted like I like the way you
move that the big boy song yeah and uh
em so we called Outkast people were like
we're like in a sort of our hand hat in
hand we're like could we do you think we
could get and they're like the only way
we'll let you use the song as if you
have them on the show more like you
[ __ ] pretended to be mad like
oh you mother wicked will call you back
it was like oh great that noise you hear
is it magic I fiving everybody yeah I
was like oh great okay yeah you can come
on the show Oh awesome yeah but that's
just like it's kind of not it's not not
worth it but but you're right about it
being about culture a great sketch show
yeah but but it was whose it was more of
this all-encompassing embrace of culture
for everyone it that sounds weird but
like I'm I'm his into hip-hop as any
yeah black dude Patrice and I'm we used
to fight about that and I'm that's when
I was a kid I remember shame Patrice and
I used to fight about it doesn't really
indicate anything other than you talk to
Patrice about something he tried to one
that one night he was gave me a lesson
and in what real hip-hop blackout listen
to god so like and then then dissected a
jay-z song for me yeah and was like it
so it but but you know I don't think
that just because you're black doesn't
mean hip-hop oh isn't for you you know
what I mean yeah and so that's what I
that's what I say about like that show
is why I member i got most defs album as
soon as that [ __ ] you did that yeah
that that albums amazing to his first
album is his only real but I mean I
guess he's made other ones but that I'm
I wore that album out yeah I didn't that
[ __ ] a lot first time I ever heard hip
hop was roxanne shante in norristown
philadelphia yeah i was in northtown
photo uh-huh illy yeah mom I'm you know
my cousins grow up next to you right now
yup who my cousin Andrew who edits his
podcast absence a living oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah they literally live across
your mom have you have you have you run
into Andrew here no I don't think so
he's friends with Kalyn Oh
talent and he hangs out like does goes
he's one of the hardest-working [ __ ]
dudes he's kind of guys it's like I'm
not gonna get drunk until I I'm proud of
myself out in the city and you're like
holy [ __ ] I gotta hook you guys up yeah
deal because is he in k is he trying to
be in showbiz or what's he doing he's
editing my podcast he's working on he's
working on like a Hallmark show that
words I think its guests stuff him he
was with Brewer yesterday okay so he's
hangs out a lot of comics and then you
know like just does all the stuff that
like cam will have these like eccentric
dinners where he brings all his
interesting people and always invites my
cousin Andrew well that's great yeah um
your brother was my first connection in
comedy I didn't when I got into comedy
my cousin my uncle dave said talked
Kevin Brennan Kevin Brian's friends of
the family I want to high school with
them um he'll be that he uh we I talked
to his we talked to his mom his mom
talked to called Kevin and can I feel
like I vaguely remember this cuz you
know there's nothing worse than like
someone's gonna call you and yours oh uh
so I go to the show I go to a show yeah
it kind of the seller Kevin's on stage
and I went there to meet him so I could
say hey my name's bird i'ma get in the
comedy and he did crowd work he's and he
started messing with me and so that's
how I met her and I talked to him
afterwards as I go go's catch rising
star party I'll talk to you over there
you could tell I mean now I don't even
really know him but like now knowing him
what I did is like the last guy you
should yeah how you asked for anything
like that yeah oh sorry what a catch
party it is I went up to him again I was
like and he goes no no my buddy has got
this taken care of he's gonna talk to
you any introduced me to tell but then
but you were already out there you
already in New York right what year
wasn't this is 97 no I would oh I'd
we've written half baked by then yeah
yes I lived out here yeah but you would
I remember you I lived in New York and
then I moved back I lived in New York to
like from like 91 294 moved out here and
then move back to New York and like 98
yeah and then when I first moved out to
LA these sit with this girl Rachel I
remember last night I was dating and
they were like oh yeah are
our buddy Neal Brennan has got I'm is
first time I word the word hutzpah
solaris and they're like he's right he
wrote a movie called half baked I go a
title that guy I [ __ ] like it but I
didn't know you and then the first time
ever met you was sitting at the improv
your good friend Steve Byrne yeah and we
started talking about a world war two
documentary from which one the I think
can't burn the war yeah yeah yeah and uh
and I was like yeah so but I've been a
fan of yours for [ __ ] ever thanks man
so how what was the how hard was it to
get half-baked made not hard at all that
was I was telling literally talking to
somebody about it last night because the
thing about half-baked that people seem
to forget or whatever because it's like
sort of sort of like beloved is uh that
it [ __ ] [ __ ] the bed when it came out
and me and schapelle were like put in
jail like career wise haim especially
like he was [ __ ] they literally said
on CNN his career is over when
half-baked came up really one hundred
percent we know that happens the easiest
production in the history the easiest we
pitched it in March we pitched it in
March started shooting in July is that
right yeah all right let's say we
pitched it in February started shooting
in July really hitched it no no script
just pitch to hitched it then we wrote
the script in like we had six we pitched
the way came about it's pretty funny
like all right so manage my friends we
never we never really written anything
together but like I'd sort of like say
hey maybe say this and whatever I was
just writing for like dating i wrote for
like singled out and [ __ ] like that and
so I go like give him tags or whatever
and and did the same thing with jay mohr
and so so he went I I wrote a script
that was very good but like someone was
like at this production company this Bob
Simon's who produce sandwich mummys
someone who worked for him was like hey
we should meet with this kid Neil he's
whatever so I met with her and I was
really funny the main I was like
it's not a great script but I was funny
I mean I'd hutzpah and then what we used
to go hoods but back in the 20s and uh
isn't great like in in six years we're
gonna say the 20s and it's gonna be the
2020 so [ __ ] I never thought about that
yeah it's coming Burt [ __ ] the wrong
so so then I met with Bob Simon's the
main producer and I was really funny in
that meeting but again my skirt wasn't
good so so then Chappell met with him
like three weeks later completely having
nothing to do with me and he's like hey
you have any ideas and dave was like
yeah I'm writing this weed movie with my
buddy they're like who and he was like
you never heard one trust me cuz
Chappelle was like I had told his agents
I want to write someone Neil and I like
don't write with that [ __ ] weird dude
and then so the the the the Bob sounds
like who who's your buddy and he's like
you've never he's like just who is any
good Neal Brennan and he's like oh we
love Neil he was just here when can you
guys pitch this movie and Dave's like
and I don't know we haven't whatever so
Chappelle literally leaves the meeting
call amigos hey if universal calls you
say we're writing a weed movie we've
never talked about this ever we'd seen
trainspotting together and he was like
they'd be fun to do a weed version of
that but we didn't really that was it
that was literally the extent of the
conversation so then universal calls
here like are you guys writing I'm we
move I was like yeah right there we'd
movie sure yeah when can you pitch and I
was like we can pitch it in a month and
and then we took the full month to
outline it we literally waited till the
night before outlined it at the Davis
stay at the mondrian across the comedy
store and we had like.we started in the
afternoon it was like a Sunday we did
pitch in on Monday morning and we just
like figured out it was funny like
seeing Chappelle's brain because there's
a movie there's a book called the
writers journey that's like the best
screenwriting book really yeah it's
amazing
recommend to anyone who's vaguely
interested in screenwriting it's the
best screenwriting book you'll ever read
[ __ ] 42 / sampling okay well this'll
help so it was like I Chappelle read it
he was like okay and then I brought
index cards and we were outlining and
like sit once he saw it he could
completely understand like how to do it
and so then we picture the next morning
and they were like this is great then we
pitched it to like universal that week
and they you know we didn't make a lot
of money for it but like but and then it
came out first of all like the
production was like crazy because like
no one really listened to us like we
remember I remember getting on set insha
belgaum like is this how I pictured it
knows i know this is how you fiction
usually know like it wasn't supposed to
be that colorful and [ __ ] it was
supposed to be like fairly realistic
looking that colorful that's interesting
that you say that there was a yeah it
was awful it's just like goofy some
goofy [ __ ] like we wanted it to be like
real like we wanted to look like that
movie kids like just like a bunch of do
to New York like with some sort of like
goofy parts but you know and maybe
that's why it succeed I don't know why
it's exciting part of the reason it
succeeds is it was fairly popular and
then Chapelle show hit and it became
like this thing but before that it was
like yeah it's a funny movie yeah it was
I remember hearing about it i just
started work in the north of boston
comedy club which i also did yeah really
yeah dude yeah I think I knew that I
think I did that like when I when I i
was going to NYU film school and working
I'd worth the door with like Jason
Steinberg and I was first guy i bet that
is this yeah i met Jason through my
brother like when I was in high school
so so yeah I'd worked at door Jason and
uh and then that's a weirdly good job
yeah it's a good job in terms of like
whenever I see an agent or somebody
hanging out at comedy clubs its young
I'm like dude you're smart because
that's there's no better way to like get
a feel for showbiz and talent than just
working
working at a comedy club and like seeing
who does well seeing what they're like
seeing like what other people think of
that person seeing like you can see
people just the flyer I used to hang out
right above that oh I used to hang out
hand out that flyer I know that I know
that yeah I know that I yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy Jordan Reuben maceo it's
[ __ ] hilarious um yeah like that
almost gives me a panic attack saying
that it did it did a lot of good for me
in hosting TV shows so like like I i'm
naturally a quad this sounds crazy but
naturally like a more quiet really
reserved person yeah I think it's a over
compensation for my social anxiety that
may I Bellino that you say that I can
see that yeah and so um but that job
that job of having to walk up to
strangers on the street yeah really got
me out of my shell and really taught me
how to talk to strangers and I didn't
know how to do that I'd grown a school
in Tallahassee had a small town
ultimately but like I knew how to be big
and loud and drunk I didn't know how to
like be be like charming beat ya and
gregarious and go hey you guys want to
see a show yeah it really did a lot to
jobs a lot for me I think I learned a
lot about comedy to just watching yeah
that's the thing it I remember the other
thing is like you remember I worked
there 92 93 94 and like the average show
was Chappelle jay mohr Jon Stewart Ray
Romano like I remember talking someone
going like what's going to happen to Ray
I know that's a and I that people that
it would seem crazy now but like he was
on news radio and got fired and Joe
Rogan replaced him yeah and it's like
when you get fire from a pilot that gets
picked up that's a bad that's a bad
[ __ ] thing you know who else set up
into crew carrie oh alright yeah that's
another like showbiz story that i would
like that having been around so long i
remember being at the improv with
Chappelle in 95 96 and drew carey
he was talking he goes yeah I hope your
show fails and Davis is like Jesus drew
the [ __ ] is wrong with the owner was
like well you know it's want my show to
do good like his drews was it was just
kind of like a weird thing to say but
like that's how when people talk about
Jim like I've been doing the [ __ ] so
[ __ ] long you've been in this
business yeah much longer than I I mean
I've been in this business a while but
I'm but you've been in it another
[ __ ] 10 years before me I've been in
it like real like half-baked was came
out 97 18 years ago we wrote it in a
movie aight a studio movie [ __ ] 18
years ago so whenever someone's talking
to me about show biz I'm like so what
else tell me what else yeah what it did
teach me about all this like I'm [ __ ]
been around this [ __ ] for it like it's
like it positive experience bat like
negative really negative experiences
have been hot cold hot cold hot like
just to the point of like I don't even
are you numb to the heat no uh well no
well I'm numb today I'm numb to it in
that like I know I've never capitalized
on it well you're you are you are an
interesting person in this business
because you have worked steadily yeah
for [ __ ] probably 20 years yeah but
but you you are someone that it's I feel
like it i think it's your comedian
spirit is like this you're humbled like
like you'd like the [ __ ] ultimate
pinnacle of at what everyone wants
showrunning executive producing the
greatest comedy sketch show ever yeah
and then [ __ ] it just falls apart
yeah great now I gotta start all over
from it but its but the thing about show
business is you always have to start
over do you never it's like did you know
more cronin yeah I know Mark running
really well like it we wrote on singled
out together that's why I Ya Ya Konan
SAT me down with a bottle of scotch in
his office when I worked on the X show
ya the day got cancelled bored me a
scotch he took a scotch and he said
there's something you need to learn all
shows get cancelled yeah and I remember
going oh [ __ ] I guess yeah is what did
you do on the exa over the host yeah I
things like all shows get cancelled and
he's like you need to get comfortable
with that because if you
not gonna get comfortable at you can't
work in this business yeah he's had Burt
you're gonna be on show is better than
this and shows worse than this and
they're all getting canceled and I
remember even like end of trip that we
just entered our fourth season and one
of the younger girls on the show but
Kate was in my room helping me pack and
it were is that what you call [ __ ]
yeah yeah and so she's she's are named
Heidi she's a really sweet girl but
she's from me this season was the first
time she had ever rented a car in her
life great so like she really is like
just and she said what if do you think
we're getting canceled like that's why
her brain thinks and I'm like no I'm I I
that's why my brain I'm like no like if
we do you got to be quote that that you
know it's part of the game yeah it's
they're all getting canceled yeah and so
it's that's one of the best lessons to
learn is that there is going to be
failures and the other thing is no one
is like has a green light no one has an
unconditional green light you know who's
trying to find a script right now to be
in tom cruise yeah will smith like I'm
not [ __ ] around like every director
there's no Judd is looking for something
like everyone's always looking for a
thing to do and there's no and then once
you get it you have to kind of like
prove that it's a worthwhile thing you
they don't just go yeah if I can go do
it there's 50 50 million dollars just go
do the [ __ ] like every like so when
people whatever i'm directing something
in and an actor will go I don't want to
I don't want to read I don't want to go
in an audition and I was like well guess
what I didn't want to pitch so we're but
I did I didn't want to have to pitch but
I did so so let's just uh [ __ ] Asian oh
um if you feel free to take it not
everything the not [ __ ] that guy yes so
so the idea that somehow I but the good
news is like half-baked happened more
the only thing that bothers me is I know
how fleeting all this stuff is like I
remember
two and a half baked and the the markup
you get like I remember being in a
meeting with like at Universal and with
like a bunch of executives from
Universal and the Tarantino script for
Jackie Brown had just come out like he
Chappelle edition portside read the
script and everybody was talking about
it and they're like they're like did it
and they go Neil what do you think of it
thinking like you're the [ __ ] you
know this amazing I like wood and I was
that and I remember thinking like that's
where that tone is not appropriate but
like that's completely unnecessary like
a good but what the funny thing
Chappelle so smart when we turn when
havoc look like it was going to get made
he goes he goes congratulations you're a
witch doctor he's like you're now like
this weird thing that people are gonna
look to for like you've got this crazy
you know something that other people
don't know and he just knew it from
being around the [ __ ] so and then it
came out so we were like hot from the
script then it comes out get a project
right after it yeah and I ended up not
doing any of them I was supposed to well
no here's what happened I did it I me
and brewer was supposed to read a movie
and Brewer fired me I swear to God
really yeah me brew and Tracey had to
rent a movie and Brewer fireman really
yeah and then and what's hilarious is
two years ago I saw Brewer Montreal and
I was just sort of like sort of like
didn't have a lot to say to him like
just like insecure and defensive so he
said to somebody he said to like Tom pop
he's like really bum like Neil I thought
me I was like super happy to see Neil
and he was treated me like [ __ ] and I
was like does he not remember firing me
he fired me from a movie I'm not going
to like and he forgot he didn't remember
it really yeah he had no recollection I
was like yeah dude I don't like you're
like you don't represent good [ __ ] to me
so so like got fired from by brewer than
I did then I i sold a couple movies that
and and that was fun to like sell movies
on my own son with this guy make sure
who created Parks and Rec knowledge but
like back then he was just a writer for
SNL and that was really cool but
i saw i went to a premiere of after
half-baked i went to the premiere of
Bowfinger this is in 1999 or 98 99 and I
remember seeing all the universal execs
and they looked at me like I [ __ ] had
AIDS and they didn't want to get it on
them and I was like I made the decision
like oh I'm hey I'm never going in
another Premier that's [ __ ] off the
top yeah and also like I see how this
[ __ ] works it's just like everyone out
here is pretty much Don King so if
you're doing well they always believed
in you yeah and if you're not they just
have no time for you so the only thing
that gets me mad still is people buying
it people believing that you're only as
talented as the last thing you did and
the thing that drives me crazy it's
other [ __ ] artists yeah like friends
of mine that like won't use me on [ __ ]
and then and it like they'd rather use
somebody else and I'm like are you
[ __ ] why would you hire somebody like
we're friends and you know I'm funny why
would you use somebody else and it's
like well they're hotter than they don't
say it's like they're hotter than you
and it's like are you [ __ ] ki guess
who was you know couldn't have been less
hot when we started Chappelle Joe
chapell he was [ __ ] I remember
telling I was like dude you're gonna
have a career but they're gonna make
after half a came out I go you're gonna
have and he did that movie dirty work
with normal [ __ ] the bed and I was like
they I go you can have a career but
they're gonna make you walk back yeah
they just dropped you off in the middle
of the desert you gotta walk back I mean
if you think about it everything he had
done I mean arguably up until the
Chappelle show is a failure yeah hundred
percent I mean more opportunity probably
than anyone in the business ten pilots
yeah and and everything was a failure
and then all of a sudden that except his
HBO special which is great but even that
what's considered a failure by HBO
because it didn't do it Chris Rock's did
yeah and I remember I remember watching
it I remember watching it with another
comedian and and and thinking oh this is
going to be compared to Chris Rock's
best
it's and it doesn't have the it's not to
create it's not Chris roxburgh right
nothing nothing now having said that so
this is how this is what i love about
spell he HBO was just like sitting on it
and she was like hey you guys would you
can you release it on DVD and they're
like now and I can really somebody
because he goes do you mind giving me
the rights and I can release it they
were like yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
and then Chappelle show came out and he
sold a million of them I bet he did he
literally sold a million of them and
owned it so like that's how like that's
how cold he was so the fact that I know
people that would rather work with so
and soaks they're hot and I just did
something that I think is going to make
me hot again and I'm already waiting for
people to go I literally showed it to
somebody and they go man we should do
something together [ __ ] out of here like
get the [ __ ] away from me like two
minutes ago you didn't think that and
that like so do you think i lost the
talent that I directed [ __ ] Rick
James do you think that's gone yeah do
you think it's just yeah just I lost it
I literally was down the 405 and it
[ __ ] flew out of my car yeah all my
talent flew out of my car but people are
so insecure and I'm one of these people
is like I'm loyal like I'll [ __ ] i'll
do i'll [ __ ] with anybody if we're cool
like a literally i'll [ __ ] with anybody
if we're cool like I'll whatever it's
like I'll help you on your bowel do any
I don't give a [ __ ] like I'm not I don't
think you're gonna pull me down you know
the main ya like so it's like yeah I'll
work with I'm not like I would like a
the other good thing about like being
fairly successful is like now I can just
work with people I like so I don't have
to take just random jobs i'll just work
with people that I know and like and
what the thing about schapelle show that
taught me more than anything is like you
you're giving a lot of life force over
to these shows and these projects like
it's a lot of it's a lot of time and
it's a lot of energy as a lot of thought
so if you don't like the
person it's not you can't do it ya can't
do it its life force is an interesting
word because I feel like I I feel like I
dumped a lot of life force and stuff
sometime whenever I'd have a project
yeah I'm sure you do and then and then
all of a sudden I go I must like I just
got done then my side get back on tour
and I'm like god damn it ma'am I haven't
given any life forced to my stand-up
yeah my stand-up just been sitting there
and that's the only thing that's ever
been there every time you come back
every time you come back your stand-ups
like yeah and I keep thinking to myself
I'm like I don't [ __ ] focus on stand
up I will be that guy that just does
just just it pass them by yeah literally
and we're talking about this right when
we got here but like you know bill and
Jim are both doing bus tours I'm not not
that I couldn't not that I gym two
airframes bill burr J job yeah um but
sounds like to our friends bill and Jim
are giving tours of Beverly Hills I am
NOT I the door please yeah but yeah but
I go I need to [ __ ] really focus I'm
sent an email last night mapping out a
12 city tour that I wanted to do and
then i was like i don't even really need
a bus i could just get a rental car into
it yeah and and just an hotels and be
probably a little more comfortable and
take great a month ok but uh but like I
was like yeah I need to [ __ ] him for
everything I've ever gotten I've gotten
from comedy clubs yeah I mean literally
every like everything I got the first
fight of my career was new Dave to
comedy clubs and then based on that I
got stuff and then me and David
Chappelle show and then it all comes
back to like you know like Chris Rock
didn't know I was funny until he we were
Facebook friends and he would see my
tweets and Facebook sand he bright like
funny like yeah rock yeah like any we do
shows at the cellar and you'd be like oh
yeah like you gotta be there's got to be
a little bit of a like like like you're
you're helping people write jokes you're
tagging jokes for people yeah and you're
and then you're going off in directing
movies and you're still the guy behind
the scenes and there's got to be a part
of you that's like [ __ ] this I need to
be on in front well yeah by it's not
even so [ __ ] this it's more that like
force thing it's like it's like it's so
much time and so much energy that I'd
like to reap the reward of being able to
sell out theaters you know or sellout
clubs or whatever like I'd like that
reward and I've been doing more that
lately like I've done a bunch of pilots
and I'm doing two now and addressing or
no i'm in amin writing them and all the
[ __ ] like so so uh that's the thing of
like that's the frustrating part about
being quote unquote behind the scenes is
like i'll be on shows with five other
people who were who don't know how to
direct or right and people will i'll
kill just as hard as them and people go
well we should use have nilsa
behind-the-scenes kind it's like
[ __ ] we were on the same stage I
killed just as hard as them why am i
disqualified from whatever job because I
know how to direct like well the the
thing the things fascinating in my
opinion is I've always there's an actual
fear that goes into me so like I've
always been a guy that gets deals and
then we make it or don't make it and
then they just really write a script
this really [ __ ] difficult to
translate funny onto a screen yeah it's
so I only have one joke that I've ever
put into something I shot and directed
my cellar shot I shot and produced and
wrote some another another kid directed
it there's only one joke I've ever
written there's a big party scene dude
passes out Lee all get markers to write
on him and then it kind of swipes and as
we pull away it's a black dude it's uh
it's what's the guy's name buckeye
Darrell right it yeah those my white guy
to Daryl right it's the only thing I've
ever written that I went yeah actually
someone washed away oh that's funny ya
ever [ __ ] ever I can do one hour and
45 minutes non-stop laughter but when it
comes to creating well there's it but
because people don't know the difference
people don't people don't know the
difference the reason that works is
because it's visual the thing of
uh it's like there's a thing in movie
writing where they're like movies are
show me medium not a tell me medium
meaning don't uh have a character talk
about the time they did this flash do a
flashback show it so with stand up there
was a show on Comedy Central called like
mashup I think where they would do TJ
Miller did it and they would do like
visualizations of people's jokes and it
didn't work because it's more fun to
imagine it yourself based on what
someone saying yeah than it is to just
see it in certain respects that's the
thing about comedies we can conjure a
stand-up you can conjure up an image for
someone just talking and that's what's
cool about it so once you so if you just
actually show it it's kind of like kind
of just doesn't it's kind of flat a lot
of the time unless it's like an original
idea that's visual that's done best
visually like that's a visual joke so of
course it worked yeah and but it is
tough and I think that I also think
there's this proprietorship that that
people in this business have where they
go they don't want people to to cross
over yeah they don't want they don't
want you to be onstage funny sitcom
funny like you know think of it is like
what you to do yeah but it came to the
party you know look at the Emmys it's
all its Tina Louie Larry David it's all
people that can do both you ever feel
like though do you ever feel like Louise
the only one I mean Tina tube Tina Tina
you're I guess you and everyone used
aimed but like I feel like I feel like I
always felt like you'd go into a sitcom
and you'd go in I go I'm a comic I'm
gonna sit in the writers room they'd be
like duh it's okay we got well that the
reason I don't want you in there it's
cuz they don't want you fighting they
think you're gonna fight just to give
your character jokes yeah I would never
do that I want this show to be funny
right but they don't know that they
don't assume that i mean my first deal
ever i remember pitching the guy a joke
and he goes I got it okay and I went oh
yeah he's like you know you got hired to
star in it star in it I'll let me write
it and I went I'm i don't i don't want a
story by credit like I don't yeah I just
want this to be as good as possible well
yeah because people want to feel like it
was them it was their thing yeah I did
it whereas you know what it if your
first of all you're gonna get the credit
either way whoever it's like me and Dave
along when we were doing half-baked
realized we were like Dave's gonna get
all the credit and comedy and I'm gonna
get all the credit in show business so
in the stand-up world I was a [ __ ]
door man so I was dormant in 1994
writing movie in 1997 like Jeff Ross
refer to me as Dave Chappelle's typist
you know domain like like so I am put in
everyone thought either I'm a genius and
Dave's a [ __ ] or a memoir on Dave's
like could be just two geniuses yeah or
just too talented people yeah I to tell
you little genius like this [ __ ] fine
like why can't there be that like
because it because that is thing when
people go who wrote that joke me they
would never say who wrote it cuz people
the only reason people want to know is
so they can discount the other person
yeah so yeah so that's the thing if
people don't want uh yeah they want you
to just do that if that's what you're
hired for yeah but it's hard like that's
the thing is that all these jobs running
a show and all that [ __ ] is really hard
and it's like really draining so so
that's kind of my thing of like I'm not
gonna get in I'm not going to do
anything unless I really really like the
person yeah um and so far Who am I work
I mean the last couple years the only
people I've worked with their like Chris
Rock I helped him with his movie Seth
Meyers I'll help with top five know
about to proof set who's that Tony
Hernandez oh yeah and I'll help Seth
Meyers out with like the Correspondents
Dinner and then I did a thing I like
doing short stuff to I don't like being
locked into some [ __ ] for nine months
yeah where you can't do anything else
just like this again I wouldn't mind
being locked into my own thing but I
don't to be locked into somebody else's
show and like yeah have to go and
the an interesting thing having worked
as I was when you're the when you run a
show like Chappelle show if the person's
name is on it and it's their show
ostensibly I was your I was afraid of
Dave the whole time when you have one of
those jobs if you're Rob Burnett if
you're the person who runs so-and-so
show that person your career can be over
in a second meaning if the person if you
look at the person funny or if you say
something to their wife or you know I
mean like so like yeah like you can like
my Chappelle show was over like that it
wasn't cuz of me but it was over like
that like I know people that have been
fired Robert Morten ran Letterman until
just he didn't like you have to sort of
you're basically like the Secretary of
State you're the vice president you're
and you're also sort of like a
handmaiden or you're just like I've
created some jokes for you sir yeah your
material for the day and and so I
realized like oh I don't want to be
afraid of somebody so last summer I
hosted a show on sundance and and what I
came to realize is like then I was
afraid of the audience you're never not
afraid of somebody yeah you know I mean
there's never not someone there's never
not a mouth to feed even Rupert Murdoch
is afraid of stockholders like so
there's it goes back to the thing of
like there's no perfect job there's no
green light yeah there's no green light
for any but like you have to be good
every kind of like every time or people
are more people are like [ __ ] you I
remember gettin in his hand up thinking
why can't i bum every now and then and
then that part of the gig I remember
Barry cats took me to some Chinese
restaurant on bleecker and he was like
you gotta do your we gotta kill every
time and every [ __ ] time like at a
showcase your dad i'ma go on stage
because I was like I don't know I don't
know if I still believe in that idea but
I believe that when when I go on the
road and I'm in like Phoenix I don't
look at the show that has 200 people
differently than the show that has 500
people you know like yeah you have to
looking at Bo shows as like and and I
sometimes I go but it's the [ __ ] like I
used to say this all the time in
columbus into miami it's the third show
saturday i'm phoning it in yeah and but
you can't know yeah it'sit's you can't
find it it's got to be you got to do
your best every [ __ ] time yeah I mean
I think if there's 200 people in a
500-seat venue i'll probably be a little
slower you know I mean like I'll like
I'm not phoning it in it's just a
different energy it's a different energy
there was I had [ __ ] 45 people in my
show in Minneapolis a house comedy and
which is a big [ __ ] room on my sunday
show and man I just was like it was like
[ __ ] and this old man told me I just
wasn't funny wow I was [ __ ] two weeks
ago don't have it and I was like why do
have it oh my god I'm doing it like I'd
tell I'd tell his story and it would
kill and then if you're better than it
would just go right back to dead [ __ ]
silent yeah and then the other show he
just wanted he was like I just came here
I'm sorry on travel channel I just
wanted to talk to you after the show
about travel and where you suggest we
should go just retired know what he
[ __ ] serious yeah your travel ater
yeah let's go see that travel agent at
the house of comedy and then of course I
was like Dubrovnik he was like really I
go yet go to Dubrovnik he was like free
like oh yeah you'll [ __ ] love it just
go where's that [ __ ] her way shirt
yeah like right it's on the
Mediterranean Sea I think my my if my
map is off in my head right now but it's
it's not go to place where everyone's
going cuz it's cheap it's [ __ ]
gorgeous it's untouched it's not
steaming with tourists it's just amazing
yeah I think I think I know people that
have gone yeah and uh he's like okay all
right great great great no what about
what about the I want to go to somewhere
in the Pacific Ocean I go malao like a
plow I was at and he's like okay okay
aren't fantastic and I was like you guys
just retired he's like yeah that's okay
so I'm basically your [ __ ] travel
agent and an he'd hackle dear any eckel
me and I'm so my self-esteem is so
[ __ ] low that i SAT and talked to him
to make sure he had a good time at least
point and I told him all the places he
should go what he should do and where he
should stay in New Zealand yeah you know
what's [ __ ] up though in comedy is
like if you hadn't then you're an
[ __ ] yeah meaning like if like the
[ __ ] if you were like hey man [ __ ]
you yeah then you're a dick even though
he totally started it and completely
dismissed you and insulted you what was
it like what was it like getting out of
what was it like going on the road for
the first few times you know what's
funny about the road is like you didn't
really have any real connection with the
row now you know how many Club
connection but yeah like Road know
what's funny is I basically like I
wanted to headline I people were like
you're not know it's going to come see
you like so i would do clubs for like no
money and and people would come see me
just based on like Chapelle show and
whatever and and but what I so I'd go on
the road and for not very much money and
then and then and I was like [ __ ] them
they [ __ ] didn't draw dude and then I
was in the in the airport at like six in
the morning with my hands up at the TSA
and I was like who am I doing this for
like I realized like I was just doing it
because they said I couldn't go into
this work you're like why am I [ __ ]
great visual that's the difference
between directing and yeah king comedy
is you let me draw it in my head when
you when you said that I drew it in my
head and I giggled at you and let shirt
thats hanging but i can see you'll see
your belly button yeah and you're like
whom i do this one yeah you can like you
went to a close up in your head my of me
going of me tilting my head and going
which is funnier than if i went did it
yeah but yes so and so since then that
basically i did an hour on county
central did well etc etc and now it was
great yes i watched it i think that i
think what it premiered thank you um and
and so now just write another hour and
but i haven't gone out in the road just
cuz i made it that like I realized like
just my made a bunch of money last year
doing voiceover for samsung I do all the
commercials and I was [ __ ] home yeah
for all the note 4 and the [ __ ] s
I've and all those commercials so I was
just like I and now I it was you know
what I had a decent lead monetarily and
then once that happened I was like okay
now I was like I couldn't even see ya
poverty uh I turn around poverty was
like had passed out yeah so I was like
I'm not [ __ ] going on the road for no
money it's uh it's will here's the okay
here's my these are my Road arguments I
always say I just had this conversation
with christina pazsitzky um who's Tom
Segura wife but uh I say that I said
that the people that don't know only
because how do you pronounce your last
name paczynski virginity okay um I just
caught push she called me and was like I
don't know I mean it by the way I
probably have this conversation on air
boy she was like you know it there is
the problem that sometimes clubs don't
play that much yeah and we can go in and
do a rock venue one night sell 300
tickets of people who want to see you
you have a son yeah and you get the door
and then you walk out with like say like
seven grand hmm what cart was seven
grand depending on what and then it's
great i love it i do this thing called a
conflict to work toward where I go in
and I do radio at eight a.m. to ten and
drink on air and then go right to the
club at eleven do a show at eleven and
then I five [ __ ] home the best in the
world I don't I don't expand my audience
tho those are people that there to see
me I can't [ __ ] up it's a good feeling
knowing no one's writing a blog about
you yeah it trying something new and
knowing you got a soft cushion to fall
on yeah I love it I love it but my put
argument Christina was you can't you
don't you aren't growing your audience
so like yeah I go to dayton every year
my money in Dayton there's a ceiling on
on how much you can make and date you
know like ultimately it's not I mean
it's a great [ __ ] clockwork down that
Club of Dane yeah and uh and it's a good
scene because Dave lives [ __ ] 20
minutes from there so people are ending
her might be there yet yeah and so and
he shows up probably one [ __ ] month
yeah and um but like you know I'm not
making money and Dayton that I make and
say like DC New York LA miami tampa I'm
not making that money but I still do
that Club I still have that club because
I feel like I get an opportunity to
build an
audience for all my [ __ ] and i also have
people that don't know me and so i have
to be funny for real like i have to be
funny like when i started and so that's
that's the trade-off undoing the road as
you do build your audience and when you
do come back you know but them you know
like i said even if you don't have
bonuses and dayton if I don't have
bonuses in Dayton it's my wife is like
[ __ ] seriously and she's just like
yeah yeah but and I think that I was by
the way that's rocks argument for doing
like he doesn't believe in the make a
special and set on your website thing
cuz he's like he goes I have a lot of
fans who just got home one night we're
drunk and saw me on HBO me people who
just didn't like me we were like [ __ ]
this guy and then bring the pain came
out of her like oh this guy's pretty fun
like so he's of the same mine of like
you gotta grow your audience yeah did
you ever think about did you ever think
about having like this a cottage
industry of you directing comics
specials and helping them and helping
them whittle out the [ __ ] uh I was just
talking to somebody about it an hour ago
oh really like uh in that yeah it's like
I could totally do that I think rocks
doing that right now with Amy with
shimmer he's directing her HBO special
uh yeah my buddy Tony's producing that
too yeah yeah he did did he did he did
Christmas mommy right yessuh the crap
movies person and he's he does shimmer
she'll also does shimmer show he does
broad city yeah yeah he's a group of
them he's good he's yeah you don't even
know I've not noticed we were kids oh
god yeah we both grew up in Tampa
together and moved to New York together
oh wow and then lived across the street
he lived like just one block south of
the county cellar and I lived across the
street from the garmin cellar and so we
hung out every [ __ ] night got it um
but yeah he uh I told I wanted
Fitzsimmons to like I actually I'm
thinking oh I'm supposed to do another
special I don't know I'm kind of on the
fence if I want to do it at the DC
improv I want to do it in a club ya like
like I'm not as theater comic why would
I do it at a theater
you know yeah i don't know i mean
there's the you know the
counter-argument is uh that your it's
like and there's another rock ism he's
like that my Santa specials are an
infomercial for my live show so you know
you make it seem like he's like I cut to
the audience just to show people like
see the how much fun this is like it's
like an infirmary where they're like yes
when they cut to the crowd they're like
it does rehydrate you know so yeah like
that's the advantage of doing it a
theater she would go like this guy's a
big deal yeah i got i guess so i just
feel like my I feel I feel like
sometimes like I don't do theaters so
except for my no special yeah no I know
but um but I was I talked to fitzsimmons
and I was like a man I want I want to
say like we came up with a number like 5
grand to work with me for a weekend like
basically I just give him five grand to
come on the road with me also arguably
feature and then sit through my our
[ __ ] six times yeah and go and and
then sit with me the end of every night
sober and go okay you're [ __ ] doing
this and it kind of is a little hacky
yeah you know and just pull out the [ __ ]
you know i don't i don't i'm not with
I'm just with me on the road yeah and
and I can't take everyone I can't take
advice is so you know yeah some guy
who's a host and I'm not [ __ ] on a host
but like sometimes you're like yeah
maybe you got that advice from the guy
that you worked with before and now
you're giving me a tag for something I
don't know yeah and but i but i totally
would i as a comic I feel more
comfortable with you directing my
special than with some guy that I don't
know because I know that you know what
is funny yeah if they make sense yeah
now of course I a hundred percent thing
that like the fact that Chris Amy
special will be better because Chris is
directing it and mostly because he'll
give her tags did you direct yours yeah
you did so how does that work I did well
in that case we did they did krista lea
steve rannazzisi and mine like in the
same theater over a week they're over
whatever four days to three days but and
there was this guy Ryan pulido who
directed he was supposed to direct all
of them
so he directed renta zz's and then chris
is dad crystal his dad as a TV director
yeah like by trade like he directed he
is partners with david kelly who did
boston public and so dilly his dad
directs all those shows yeah so D'Elia
holy [ __ ] yeah so daliyah's like he's
okay alright yeah but having said that
but whenever someone tries to [ __ ] on
D'Elia no no I'm not [ __ ] on at all
about [ __ ] on him at all yeah I my
people think he's like I've heard people
go like he's rich him like shut the P
[ __ ] murders that dude suck I did a
thing with him last night he was [ __ ]
hilarious like I he's such a funny dude
but it what it did for me is I think I'd
had a dare very different picture of him
growing up I assumed he grew up in
Brooklyn oh god yeah I assumed he was
from a small Italian family in Brooklyn
him and his brother came out together
cuz i watched his brothers movie I never
wants it ever watched his brothers movie
was good I just [ __ ] very talented
yeah and I was like oh how [ __ ]
badass to others [ __ ] fighting their
way just like entourage to the top yeah
and not and that doesn't take away it
just gives me a very different story
that now is almost even more interesting
because now I feel like his dad like
directed I'm guessing I'm guessing if I
hit if I guess that's right I'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants but I was directing love
boat and he was like on the set of love
boat with his brother which isn't the
two Italian brothers man around to get
away their story I add now I it was like
it wasn't love boat it was also like
they lived in neat they lived in Jersey
until I don't till Christmas pride ten
or something then they moved out here to
the valley I just thought I just texted
back and forth of our podcast away
though I'm dying at your right now yeah
he said he's a Chrismukkah do yeah I'm
in a long time ago when he was working
with he was working with jo koy I worked
right I met him a long time ago and we
did some show where I think we brought
up two girls on stage and there's a
fight I [ __ ] remember but yeah well
as bar shows but uh you were saying
Chris yeah so so Chris's dad directed
Chris's and then I directed mine so the
all the cameras are there the basic
angles are there there's a there's a
there's a dolly in the back that but so
it's like
Ryan did a line cut of mine yeah like as
it was happening is like camera one
camera and then I but it was all like I
told some cameramen like hey do this
look directing a stand-up specials not
that hard yeah it realize no as Eddie
Murphy said it's there's four cameras
point them all of me in different sizes
wide medium tight yeah dolly it's fuggin
pretty simple but uh so-so yet so that
that's the benefit the benefit of any
director is is the best director the
thing that you get when Judd directs
your movies is tags the thing you get
when I direct the thing is tag which I
text you will make the script better
yeah meaning like when I did that the
the goods the pivotal movie like with
and Will Ferrell and Adam acade produced
and alyssa and it was all these UCB
people who were like improv and I said I
came up with just as much if not more
[ __ ] than they did like all these
improvisers because that's kind of my
thing like yeah so Judd same thing like
any anyone who's I'm sure Harold Ramis
is the same thing like I'm betting Todd
Phillips comes up funny [ __ ] like that's
kind of the job so the idea like Judds
angles aren't that special you know
mainly yeah so it's so directing for you
a comedy is is less about cuz it's
you're right you're not directing heart
of darkness you're directing a basic
basically a um a palette that everyone's
familiar with yeah don't [ __ ] it up and
then make the script better yeah don't
[ __ ] up and make the moments better yeah
you all your you're trying to get the
script better comedy-wise and then and
your job is generally and then as the
other non comedy part is like make it a
compelling watchable story movie so you
just worry about plot and tone and stuff
like that but like but yeah that's the
there's no we do a stand-up when you did
the goods uh yeah not when we were
shooting but when we were editing your
doctoring the parted already when did
you start stand up like I was gonna quit
the I basically did a little during
Chappelle show but like
you know I not did whatever yeah and
then I really started in 07 o Shah so so
yeah then did when I came out here for
the goods and uh and did you talk who
was Kevin pissed yeah really yeah he he
basically doesn't talk to me because you
serious yeah I get it like a look man
it's like if you're in show business
showbiz real competitive yeah and and
you're a family like family when so
there's already like competition yeah I
remember like at Thanksgiving one year
one of my other brothers said I was like
14 and someone said Kevin Neil's funnier
than you anyway like just like awful
[ __ ] like like so there's all right so
if you're in show business and then your
brother you help your brother get into
it which he clearly did and then at
least like the first he introduced me to
J and then I started working the door
whatever and like and then your brother
does well and people start comparing you
and go why doesn't your brother do the
use you and all this [ __ ] it's like
you're gonna get [ __ ] salty I get it
keep I know people that are not my
brother that I get salty with so imagine
if we were fighting for love also so
yeah I get it like I'm not I i don't i'm
not mad out of my understanding you guys
have a spoken I mean we'll speak every
once in a while but it's not like we're
not we used to be like cool cool now
it's like you know stinks yeah I but I'm
used it's like I'm just it's it's it's
as much a function of like an Irish
Catholic family as it is of a comedy
family yeah like it's just how [ __ ] is
like just volatile volatile people do
you guys have the whole skit spectrum of
brothers do you have like the meathead
brother and the or is it everyone kind
of like a softer sensitive
thought-provoking kind of guy no I think
I'm probably the most sort of sensitive
one then there's like sort of the
capitalist one like the old our oldest I
would say our oldest brother he was the
first one so he thought he was
gonna be an only child and then nine
more people showed up so he's and he's
never forgiven us how old is he 50
[ __ ] seven or something are you
serious um he was seven that's what
people are like I've been arguing I'm
argumentative sort of and it's like cuz
I've been arguing with [ __ ] adult
since I was five and not regular adults
these are angry people yeah who would
call me a [ __ ] and you know him like
like like these are not regular be these
are angry irish-catholic [ __ ] bitter
dudes who'd say I'm a [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
so yeah like there's there's just it's
more spectrum of like sort of weirdos
than it is like sensitive sort of I mean
assuming I'm the sensitive one yeah but
it's not it's not like it's it's you
that's 10 kids too many if you're
listening I'm sure there's not anybody
like I seek Africans like vines or
whatever yeah and the fact that he is
five kids is like what the [ __ ] are you
doing New York City yeah like what are
you doing and my parents had twice that
many and it's like it's yeah it's like
it's like growing up in a youth hostel
you personally other no um yeah I think
I knew that they got divorced basically
like when I went to college they wanted
to make sure I saw what a horrible
relationship look like they're like all
right so we got the message are let's
let's split it up let's let's uh let's
tear it down guys so Keith Robinson just
texted me Keith I saw Keith did the
seller know so [ __ ] drunk when I ran
into him that I don't remember what i
said i don't remember i said only ones i
woke up the next morning ago i think i
should have [ __ ] i should have
[ __ ] said something different I don't
know I don't know what I did but I was
like I [ __ ] rolled in and I think I
like patted him on the back I don't
[ __ ] know yeah [ __ ] just one of
those hands to be could touch his hair
found his home I stopped a joke about
that did he really I used to joke that I
got a fight with black dudes a long time
ago and I'm when I punched him in the
face is it was on my last special when I
tried to punch him in the face I missed
time my hand
high-top fade and I said you know
there's a very interesting thing about
black people that no one knows barely
but if you rub them in the right place
they fall asleep and and I wrote that in
an all-black club in Chicago because I
didn't have an end to it it was a true
story by the end of this story and it
got such a big laugh that I got
confident with it and I just said it all
the time and so then I and I you go guys
seriously try it huh Jabar commercials
ever see what happens that's funny yeah
but that's funny that's so funny at the
fall asleep thing is like that's when
you win an audience laughter that and
you go oh you're [ __ ] pretty smart
audience yeah like cuz that's a
nonlinear joke like i don't even really
know what you're referencing yeah like I
it sounds like if you touch an a a
certain animal or whatever to fall
asleep but I don't know what one you're
talking about yeah um but there i always
i have a few jokes like that were Mike
oh all right you guys got that good for
you do you have any jokes New York for
you where you go that I that's not funny
and I don't know why they laugh but I'll
keep saying it uh yeah yeah of course
for you like all right I don't think
it's especially funny but the challenge
is cutting a joke like that is if if
you'd go yeah I just don't I don't
believe it I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
want to broadcast this dislike I this
doesn't represent me oh yeah i used to i
have i have jokes my act were or i used
to i haven't told this joke and so long
I can't believe it but uh I not uh where
I would say the words and the words came
out funny but they didn't mean anything
yeah like yeah easy to have a joke about
well you have like a good person out
like you have like my jokes have to like
me I'm getting overrun cleverness it's
not like like I walk out there like will
[ __ ] mr. karisma's here like that's a
hilarious story me and Kevin were
pitching a show this is like during a
half-baked a sprite 98 99 for him
pitching a show for him yes darin and
kevin is a pretty sullen guy
so we go in a meeting or pitching and
he's being sullen and just like moon and
I'm being gregarious and charming and
and like kind of saved the meeting and
so we're walking out and Kevin looks
amigos good job sparkles like he
resented me for trying to sell a thing
for him by being charming yeah so now
that's the difference Romania was like
you're a good time Party guy I would say
like when I go on stage I'm the 50th
most fun-loving person in the room
you're the fun you're the most fun of a
guy in the town you go into might be
accurate I'm not even I don't even read
in the room like so my goods have to
work like [ __ ] oh that's really what
I don't have to work really really well
that's a really interesting insight is
that that is [ __ ] fascinating yeah
like my jokes have to my dogs have to be
airtight for leg of our stage and I
[ __ ] tear my shirt off and kill a
beer yeah everyone goes oh that's why
he's up there yeah and yeah but when you
get up there you're you're definitely
coming from the perspective of there
like ladders and people going on but I
could do this too yeah well I wouldn't
go that far when they see you they're
like no it's like well the thing that
you take away is what I like boy this
guy's very logical like that's the take
of like wouldn't mind being on a happier
with this yeah I wouldn't mind I
wouldn't my having this guy write my
term papers for me like but it's like
yeah like that's the thing of because
I'll do shows with people and it's like
some of them at the Laugh Factory I'm
like the Saturday night and I'm like
[ __ ] I'll know what joke is next I'm
like these [ __ ] people don't care
about the Pope yeah you know they are
like Catholicism
say something to do something funny
enough way but there's time from like
Jesus even want to show a Dane and
D'Elia and these guys that are just like
pure charisma okay all right writing
ability D'Elia got me on a [ __ ]
YouTube video like yeah i mean like i
watch someone do a youtube video of him
just saying how I don't even know he was
doing but it was just he is I just saw
the video of him holding the camp camera
talking to like yeah like vine elevator
oh yeah this is this is [ __ ] 12 years
ago probably he's talking in the camera
and he's got another comic in an
elevator with them and he's and I was
like [ __ ] I muah I'm in a model that
the whole video yeah one hundred percent
like that's the so yeah that's the then
there are times where I'm like now where
I'm like because I kind of have the
option between like on-camera off-camera
and there's there are times now when I'm
like these guys might just be more
trimming them like I might just be
better off just being a like a writer
and I it wouldn't be a frustrated writer
would just be like a writer director who
like is kind of charismatic there are
guys like that like David Steinberg
there are guys like that our lives very
charismatic Sandberg was the first
director I've ever worked with who
[ __ ] made me feel confident as an
actor and pulled me aside it was like he
was like you should you should be doing
a sitcom if you want to get in
development I'd love to develop with you
I was like yeah I was like holy [ __ ] and
I was hook a general meeting and then
and then in the whole meeting we just
came out that I wanted to get in
transcendental meditation because that's
what he's like really big o Israel when
I use one of the godfathers of the
movement I don't know oh ya like like as
a matter of fact I didn't take him up on
it I supposed to my might have on the
podcast I didn't take him up on it and
later got no conversation with someone
about it brought up to his name and
they're like are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah if you go in with David you're
[ __ ] you're gonna get to Nirvana yang
faster I was like [ __ ] I should have ya
done that but he's got a great series
about with comics yeah um yeah like
David Steinberger Mike Minor these guys
like so I don't like I sometime gonna
wonder like when I'm on a show with
D'Elia we did show last night and he was
so much [ __ ] funnier than me
we show the Marmot mean you are you Anya
Leia what are we doing I don't know I
just saw it on the improv maybe no store
factory with bill burr oh yeah at the
shorts the for all things coming yeah
like very kind for Mike man these guys
are [ __ ] really charismatic it's but
then you go you know in some ways the
shits like the PGA Tour like the tennis
tour or something it's like not everyone
can be ranked number one like you can be
ranked eighth and still make a million
dollars a year I'd be cool just being
like the fifth tenth best comic working
yeah I don't need to be Chappelle or
D'Elia or burr I'd be cool just being
Burt anything like and doing clubs and
selling selling out both shows friday
and saturday yeah a solid numbers
Thursday and Sunday yeah and I could do
that for a long time yeah well that's
the it's the there's part of me that
like my egos like should I just do the
thing where i'm like like I'm probably a
better director I don't know like there
are times where I'll do [ __ ] directing
wise and I'm like is this as good is
this better than my standup do you know
what I mean yeah so it's like do I just
do the thing I'm that I'm like get more
attention for or that I enjoy more or i
don't think i have to choose as the good
news you know yeah i always think like
it is tell me if it is true could you
just if you just decided I want to do a
project could you just go get it made
what it depends with the project is like
uh like what I mean like I don't know
like I look at a guy like you and I go
do you just wake up me like I think I
want to do a movie or like I think now
that sort of a saying like there's no
easy every min I mean like I mean like
like like like when I come up with a
movie idea I've got it then take it to
my managers then take it to my agents
and it usually dies somewhere in there
yeah like yeah well yeah not known for
writing scripts I don't know what we can
get you like like if I want to do if I
want to do a like a hosted reality show
meaning like what I do now if I want to
do something some of that I could get
that made to
or oh yeah like I could call up and get
15 grand to do that yeah and then give
it and I could give it too much people
yeah like this because I've just been
doing it so long could you get like I
got into a project you like i gotta i
want to do this thing it's just dip I
mean it not I still to pitch yeah yeah
like there's nothing there's no like I
said there's no green lights for anybody
what do you want to do it won't be like
a goal like a at this point I would just
like to be a like as popular a comic as
like Gaffigan like that would be that
would be like the pic that would that's
about as much I feel like that's about
as much as I could ask for yeah like but
then I also like I want to peep I want
to be in demand in all these fields is
basically what I want like I want to be
able to people to want me to direct
movies and direct commercials and direct
TV shows and do stand-up and develop a
sitcom for myself and write a movie and
like I just want to be able to do
everything get some beer not really okay
we know nothing I drink a little bit of
beer but maybe three a month oh that's
actually no beer at all yeah in my
opinion that doesn't even read on your
scale to read a month or like what what
I drinking on audition yeah yeah like
those are prop beers yeah like it just I
don't I like I just don't it just
doesn't do I don't have enough energy to
need to take it down that's interesting
and you still have a hard time waking up
a hundred percent I don't have a hot
like yeah it depends like I don't have a
heart I'm afraid I'm gonna have a hard
time yeah like I'm i live in fear of
like missing if i'm directing something
I can't [ __ ] I can't not show up like
I can't like it's a problem if I just
don't like that would be unheard of like
alia director / slim what but direct
compris latia he was just hanging out
and his dog and then yeah it's
interesting i always had the i remember
doing a i did something for showtime
some
I hosted something Russell Peters hosted
it but I did like man on the street
stuff and uh us to this you know stew
over it triage still smiling that's too
sure I'm gonna shock his last name up
anyway Stu's the executive producer the
whole [ __ ] thing he owns the whole
[ __ ] company and he's the executive
producer of the show also and I get down
call time I'm like you know five minutes
late the way I ballpark all times yeah
it's it's a blurred the call time in my
opinion some host yeah and I rolled down
he's waiting in the van for me and I was
like what are you doing here so early he
goes call times a very specific thing I
made my call time and I was like oh and
then ever since I was like I guess I
can't just [ __ ] be the last one to
call time every [ __ ] time yeah I it
depends what I'm doing yeah if I'm
directing like I'm very early yeah if
I'm in it I'll look at the call sheet
and know when I need when I need to get
there yeah cuz I just know from
directing like [ __ ] need me to sit
and make up for an hour and 45 minutes
like I'm a I'm not going to and be its I
when you're the talent quote-unquote the
on-screen you're treated like an animal
and that's like I try not to when I'm
directing like is they you can't the
thing I explain to people is like when
Tom Cruise has a meltdown or whatever
when so-and-so yells on set yeah it's
because when you're on screen you can't
[ __ ] leave set so like if I want
coffee in my life I go get coffee if I
need coffee and I'm on set they go we're
gonna write it down then we're gonna
have a PA go get it for you and it's
going to take an hour and 40 minutes and
then when it gets there and it's wrong
you're like you [ __ ] I could
have gotten this myself in 10 yeah so
that's the thing of like that's why
people get pissed on set is because
you're your captive you're like an
animal yeah um so so yeah I'm I can be a
dick in terms of like when I'm telling
where i'll be like they'll be like what
a little late I'm like did you need me
like you know what time I needed to get
here oh well my old thing has always
been with uh with crews needing to rig
stuff and I go like I remember going i
remember my thing that drives
[ __ ] nuts is when you work with the
director or a producer who's unfamiliar
with how shooting works in the field
mm-hmm and they're like and you're like
the call times eight we'll see you down
here now yeah but you aren't gonna need
me into like 930 yeah and he's like no
no i'd like to have you on set i'm like
man that's not gonna happen yes they
stuff to build cameras they've got a
[ __ ] connect audio like they've got a
lot of work lot of [ __ ] to do but I
don't need to be there for he's like why
the cameras were made I'm like nope
camera help they're all in boxes yep
they're never [ __ ] made yeah I'm like
how dare you not know a [ __ ] thing
yeah and like that's with the thing that
always [ __ ] what would you rather do
would you rather do a movie or sitcom or
just a stand-up tour so you got one year
of your life [ __ ] full-on do vote
what did you call it the the the heart
motions what did you call it life life
force what do you what would you like to
devote your life force ah probably a
stand-up tour why don't we do an all
things comedy stand-up tour because no
one we don't draw a different way I know
but it's not like we're like oh it's to
all things comedy guys we're not like a
known engineer who's on our list it's
you linger uh-oh should have a
completely different yeah fan base than
mine yeah like I would venture to say I
know I listen y'all's podcast but like I
don't like you guys definitely hit a
different market yet for sure um and by
that you mean black people yeah yeah
black people and put a lot of white
people said why people also the one you
did with riffraff which was
uncomfortable as far as the best what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was so [ __ ] hilarious
cuz i was like oh together he's out of
his mind he's a drug addict yes so yeah
I don't know Russell no star look like
oh yeah I know yeah like I would I think
I'd want to go on tour yeah but but then
now but it's knowing how life is people
are really bad at predicting what's
going to make them happy so i could go
on tour and then be like I [ __ ] hate
this although I don't think I a bus tour
to me would be like the best right yeah
why don't we do in all things call me
bus tour because I don't think people
know
there's not I like people wouldn't go
people go all things happen was that
even mean yeah um I guess we wouldn't be
able to use our moniker we could but I
don't think it would help who could be
on me you segura me Sarah Moshe yeah
like me and I feel like Segura and our
show have a like a crossover really yeah
just cuz like a lot he talks about black
people a lot I although I think his is
more for white people than ours is
because we actually know black people
worse all of his are just things he saw
at the store [ __ ] hilarious but uh yes
so so so yeah i think but i also don't
know like i just did something that was
so goddamn fun I just directed a
commercial it was like a nine-day shoot
and it was probably the greatest job
I've ever had in my life really yeah it
was before nike shut oh no i just did a
nine-day nike shoot and it was the
[ __ ] best what was it what did you
have athletes in it yeah um i don't know
if i can talk about it yet here's what i
can talk about I got it was nine days it
was six day they basically came to me to
write something because I did something
for Jordan for air jordan with Blake
Griffin and Chris Paul and air jordan
top right oh yeah and yeah oh yeah by
the way when you direct a thing you can
take anything you want so when I go on
the Wardrobe truck I'd be like hey can I
there like you take anything I was like
oh the [ __ ] up yeah so I did I like
there's so much [ __ ] I didn't take from
Jordan these are new nike like by the
way Todd glass is calling me but so you
know that's I think that speaks to the
levels were at you gotcha peled yeah and
I got ya yeah like so I direct so yeah
it's like nine days six here six in LA
to in spain won in hold on i'm sorry
england this nike commercial two days in
Spain yeah one in
lind yeah I can't six here that's it so
it's got to be landmarks that you're in
front of uh I mean why would you go to a
studio in Spain it was more about
athletes oh really yeah oh [ __ ] but it
was so it's gonna be [ __ ] bananas
yeah it's a star-studded it's but i
would say they wanted me to write
something so I was like I'll write it if
I can direct it and they were like my
right thinking it wouldn't it was
supposed to be just like an online thing
yeah and then it kept snowballing into
this thing and they were cool enough to
like let me direct it because I've never
durrington Nike commercial like I've
never directed a commercial that big
before so it was like it was like uh
yeah they honored it and it did the
commercial turned out really well and
it's like [ __ ] the best it was so fun
isn't it was so fun just telling cuz
it's basically directing an action but
because there's not a lot of dialogue
yeah so it's just like hey famous
athlete run and I'll film it yeah that's
what it is it's filming at its figuring
out a cool way to shoot athletes doing
athletic [ __ ] crazy so could you
theoretically if you were interested in
it could you I mean obviously I maybe
that would be a step back in your career
but could you come up with a bunch of
like fun ask badass commercials and yeah
and I don't think it would be a step
back the money my opinion I'll tell you
the budget off camera yeah the budget
for the commercial was higher than the
entire first season of Chappelle holy
[ __ ] yeah so uh I got the DP from fight
club and don't gone girl I got Fincher's
DP and they're like is that ok I'm like
yeah yeah that's fine that'll be fine
someone will start airing this saturday
but but the big rollout is like july
second so oh this is interesting it the
converse is going to air in china and if
you want a commercial to air in China
you have to give it to the Chinese
government a month before so they can
scrub it for anti-communist messages
serious yeah see I would probably I'm
not even joking I
probably tap out of everything i'm doing
to just direct commercials I look I yeah
that's it was really fun i'll say that
like if I could just the thing about
commercial is like it's another one of
those like really inconsistent things
though you can be hot I could get hot
from this commercial or not like I don't
know so you can it's there's no there's
very few people that have like a
long-term steady stream of work that you
can be like a good director for like a
famous director for like 30 years or in
whatever there are people that have put
together like five year runs tenure
around 15 year on I'd love to do it and
again the thing that they get is punch
up like I was like the ending of the
commercial was something I told one of
the athletes to do and they were like
and I was like trust me it'll be cool
save your punch up sometimes for be you
do you think of it earlier like oh you
do now Nigel what I know because you
want to get the job oh yeah yeah oh you
wanted to be good and like because the
other thing if you give a good punch up
early then when you're on set hopefully
you think of a better one but but yeah
it was the coolest [ __ ] all these
like super name it's not Fame it's like
they're famous athletes but like it was
cool just to its you know what I like
about it's the access of like when I
show you the spot I'll show you off
camera I'm sorry like maybe I can come
back when it airs we talked about but
like just having these people do their
thing uh and like was it's like it's
like it's like the toy you know I mean
it's like you're you I'm like it's an
man it's not like the toy and not like I
abuse it but it's just that I know how
cool it is to get so such and such to
run or and the other cool thing was some
of the athletes were in high school when
Chapelle show was on so they were like
really excited to meet my shut the fukk
which was like the best um so say yes oh
I would do that like I hopefully i can
do that a lot of that but and and like
now I'm friends with the guy who did
fight club so he'll like he and I was
jut Apatow
email me like hey who was the DP on the
goods was a good nose like it was great
only by the way I just work with this
guy Jeff who you might use maybe use him
and he was like oh yeah should I should
I work with the best DP ever yeah uh so
i texted jeff and i was like hey man i
was trying to I try to recommend you to
Jed but he said you're too famous or
some I was like I was trying to break
into comedy and Jeff wrote I'll only do
comedy with you which is like [ __ ]
the best if it's true you know i mean
like so was just a great it was just a
great experience all around it's also
cool to be funny in a in a venue that
they're not used to someone being funny
is so like being funny kind of like all
day on set people are like oh that's
usually it's like a just a dude
directing currents not like a funny
person should generally like a nice guy
or whatever great what would you do if
you if you could do it if you could do a
show a travel channel what would you
what would you want to do strums channel
always listen to my podcast always I
always have my friends when I go what
would you want to do and then they'll
just call up one day and go hit like
they actually called up and they're like
hey Russell you talk to Russell Peters
about doing a thing yeah we're
interested in that can we get his number
I was like yes sir I'm doing actually a
kind of a travel show pilot with comedy
central oh yeah yeah um I won't say what
the premises because I don't the here's
the premise I'll basically the lonely
island sandberg and those guys had an
idea for one of their buddies had it was
like hey could we do we should do a
thing where we go home with celebrities
to their hometowns and so they so lonely
I was like hey would you host it and I
was like I'll host it if when we go to
people's hometowns a plot breaks out so
like will go to the bad example it's
like we go to Philly with Bradley Cooper
and then it turns out he there's a ghost
in the house you grew up in yeah and
then he and i just have to kill the
ghost or whatever like there'll be like
a plot every year like see the landmarks
or whatever but it's ultimately about
plot B story or yeah it'll be the a
story but it'll be at the
we'll go to like Geno's it's the edge
story for a for its the a story however
for Abby story show like the horse
Iceland yeah okay yeah so we're dealing
I think how nice i'm just going to do it
that's Graham yeah but that was so like
that would be the one I wanted going
home down going to Jim Gaffigan hometown
and the rumor that he [ __ ] a goat once
hundred percent is the entire a story
yeah trying to avoid yeah and he has to
prove that he didn't [ __ ] or whatever
yeah so that that'll that'll be that
would be the tread that would be like
the show I wanted that I'm doing uh
travel channel would just be I don't
know I guess that's what are you
passionate about about the world like do
you um I think more you know the vital I
says it yeah but I've got some really
great [ __ ] oh yeah like the way it's
like sort of not like have you seen [ __ ]
that's delicious yeah hundred percent
[ __ ] love it yeah I couldn't do a
show like that cuz I'm vegetarian how
long have you been a vegetarian five six
years yeah what was it just dieter I had
a weird taste in my mouth there's
something called burning mouth syndrome
that it's like this web skewer thing
we're literally like four days a month
I'd feel like I drank hot I ate hot
pizza yeah and my mouth was burnt and I
couldn't taste anything so i thought it
was dietary so I'd stopped and then it
ended up being it went away but I think
it went away for any of for other
reasons and and so so yeah and I was I
it's not that hard i also think the meat
industry is gross and I feel like human
beings are [ __ ] the earth up so I'm
trying to help yeah but uh what do you
miss the most no I can still eat like
when I was in Europe for the shoot I
like didn't item I would i downgrade it
to vegetarian because it's like I
meeting with the crew every night I
don't want to be like we have to go to a
place called looking green grass tonight
like so I downgrade do you have a lot of
salads I have a salad for lunch to
usually but I always I did that when I
made to really yeah um I'd love to go
vegan see how long ago view you can get
you would easily go vegetarian
like I have a hard time alone really
wouldn't I don't have a problem get rid
of red meat I prob tomorrow chicken fish
I need I need here's what I've explained
to a thousand people what you're tasting
is sauce so baisley chicken fish that
stuff is basically a sauce delivery
system it's a sauce and spice delivery
system so take teriyaki sauce put it on
tofu or tempeh or Satan or beans or
whatever yeah it's the same exact taste
yeah but tofu no matter how firm never I
can always try to do buffalo tofu
there's a new one there's a new fake
chicken that had fooled a bunch of food
critics and stuff really yeah and I
camera I eat it I used to do morningstar
I used to go I would I was arguably
vegetarian for a while i was doing
morningstar everything I love this
morning star chicken things yeah those
things are [ __ ] next level I could
yeah I take those with sriracha a little
ranch oh my god [ __ ] a wolf yes down
yeah so you yeah that's what it is it's
like the [ __ ] you put on it I should
probably i'm eating clean right now I've
been eating clean for the past week just
meaning like very lean a lot of greens
like a lot of green not a lot of rice
not a lot of punch not a lot of rice not
no pasta no rice no bread great because
I just think the bread [ __ ] me up it's
ink breads really shitty free and I was
not drinking for a big stretch but moral
day happen and I just need one I might
have another drink you wanted to honor
the troops I get it oh yeah I know it's
for its for them yeah what am I don't
want to drink yeah I didn't want to do
it I was drinking tequila at club soda
cuz I was still trying to stay as clean
as possible yeah and and then I was like
all right then I'm done and then Joey
Diaz called last night he's like dog
come over our guests so I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill a bottle of wine with him
asegura and then and then tonight I'm
gonna Felipe's I know I'm gonna get
[ __ ] blitz there at his pocket yeah
he's so funny it's the best interview
I've ever done in my entire life with
him Bester did he tell you about how he
got in the county
kind not really maybe a about doing math
yeah and biting a dude's face off yeah
yeah it's the best interview I've ever
done and I guess and it was the first
time that I just really shut the [ __ ] up
and let him talk let someone talk I've
done that a couple times this one's not
so good because I kinda you were I you
were this is good I felt like this is it
you don't want to do as a podcast house
is like do a five-minute tangent about
some [ __ ] that you talk about all the
time yeah like this is good because I
[ __ ] the fascinates I took this I took I
took this step from Rogan I found what I
find to be fascinating is what this
podcast is yeah parts of your career
that I find absolutely [ __ ]
fascinating yeah like the directing and
the crossover stand up the beginning of
you storing I [ __ ] the relationship
with your family i find fascinating to
that is pretty fascinating but yes I'm
drinking tonight then I'll probably
drink tomorrow night okay the show how
about how about thursday night I'm on
the wagon but thursday thursday i'm back
they know that thursday like that and
then i got a maui in a couple in a week
so i'll be [ __ ] hardcore off are you
still doing to travel channel show still
doing travel they picked up an old show
mine that they had canceled the show
birth conquer where I did extreme rides
and and they just say like it you want
do some more I was like why to extreme
stream rides I open like thrill rides
like roller coasters and I was first
person to jump off the stratosphere
really yeah i was first person to jump
on stratosphere first person to do a lot
of rides i would go to a parks and open
the rides and I'd also like I was in
complete expert in the field i still am
I did I did rooked which is the world's
tallest waterslide like 17 stories and
you're in a thing and the guys there
will do sugar bonded it's a family
company where one of the brothers
creates all the rides and another
brother kind of is the shits on them
that's how it be in my family but they
were really except the manager was like
am excited to have you do a ride can you
tell me what you think because that's
what I did for two years on travel
channel and but yes so we'll start up if
you ever want to do if you're into
roller coasters or water parks or or
Scott I me or anything crazy well you
know what's funny is I used to get
motion sickness
and I think I don't anymore I don't
anymore either and I went on a I am in
the Big Brother's program like the Big
Brother's little britain whatever I know
that funny it's like I know like you
would never guess it and uh like I mean
the kid went to like Santa Monica Pier
and I went on like the roller coaster
there and it was [ __ ] fun yeah going
on roller coaster is really fun it's
legit I always say people who my book
money buddy cow had a says why we I just
didn't like the roller coasters but that
is the most accessible safest form of
thrill you can find a percent the people
can go I'm trusting when I say if you go
on Diamond back in in in kings island
and in Ohio that is one of the greatest
[ __ ] rides around it really is all it
is the lap belt it's barbershop seats so
your feet are dangling so when you free
fall you you it's really another jargon
by the barbershop Saints yeah well
that's my my layman's definition but
like I can but I i met with guys that
created the greatest coasters in the
world and it was like I remember one guy
saying to me I said you guys really
thought at all he goes it's [ __ ] 20
million dollars yeah it's 20 you're
looking at 20 million dollars you don't
think we covered all the bases and I was
like yeah I was like oh yeah well that's
also with safety when people are like
I'm afraid it's like do you think they
would open something you know what law
how much liability there is you know
what there's only my wife you say when I
was taught stratosphere I was freaked
the [ __ ] out and my wife kept saying to
me and this my cameraman Scott Sanskrit
saying do you realize there's one guy
that they pay simply to try to get this
not to open for insurance reasons yeah
like so you're gonna be that and I
always think about one guy that pencil
pusher in the office kalan ya know this
guy's this doesn't destroy the Vegas
stratosphere stratosphere you'd bungeed
often it's a controlled descent so it's
a 16 seconds of freefall 1100 feet you
jump and you just drop for like 16
seconds and what is it Bundy's on both
sides no it's it's it's one cord that's
on your back and there's a big like
spinning like basically like a fishing
reel at the top and as you get to the
last 40 feet it slows you down so you
land on the ground it's pretty agretti
out there and I've said this a million
times I'm trying to open one I'm not
like you I can't I'm I have ideas and
then they seem to sit in his man cave
with me and I just I look I I am plenty
of that too no but I have it like it
spades I feel like I'm trying
desperately to open a rope swing the
rope swing is the greatest I'm telling
you without a doubt rope swing like over
a pond kind of thing no so like I did a
bunch in I did a bunch in in they have
them in Switzerland and New Zealand I
did one in Africa that's where the one I
did in Africa was like pretty [ __ ]
gangster it's a Moses Mabhida Stadium
it's like 550 s the world's tallest
indoor rope swing they take it to the
stadium they connected to the dead
center of the stadium like a rope like a
climbing rope like this basically big
[ __ ] tethers that are wrong as [ __ ]
and then they dangle it to this catwalk
and you jump and you free fall arguably
the entire way and at the last second
the swing kicks in and it swings you up
and you swing back and forth I did one
in [ __ ] interlaken switzerland that
is the goddamn [ __ ] cat's pajamas
this [ __ ] thing it was like 410 feet
and you free fell I'm not even [ __ ]
with you 390 feet and at the last 10
feet it caught you and swaying you 10
feet from the bottom of this [ __ ]
Canyon you were swinging with a rock 10
feet away from your feet it was I
remember when I got done I said to
myself I am either dead and in heaven or
that was greatest goddamn thing I've
ever [ __ ] done and you probably have
adrenaline for five hours and it is
clean adrenaline you really and so I'm
trying I'm tried desperately send it out
to all my management all my agents I
said can someone please find me a
stadium the people in Africa like I you
thought you think people in show biz can
help you yeah like CA can you connive
into the roller coaster department
hay-uta yeah sorry receptor I was like
attention chris hart can someone get me
a [ __ ] prostate yo yeah and then cuz
i got these people in Africa that have
no connection but they are the greatest
company and so I was gonna try to broker
the deal get it set up Oh
rope swing premiered on my good morning
america [ __ ] and just it I feel like
that wouldn't in in engender trust of
like who who'd we get the African rope
swing people like that urban yeah like
but yeah yeah I don't think people like
oh good they're African we're in good
hands it's so funny and I dis and I
could say this you deal with the podcast
predominantly about race about you know
race whatever but what was fascinating
to me was that it was African chose all
black dudes and never in my vast time of
doing thrills never did I ever have a
black guy harness me into anything yeah
that's interesting it's always new
zealand and australian guys yeah or like
a guy with an accent well that's the
thing of like white people all of our
danger is elective it's like let me put
my see you know what i'm gonna do go put
myself in danger yeah where's like they
have to just walk home and that's as
dangerous as [ __ ] us rope swing yeah
it was interesting these guys just for
like the Heather of the okay buddy it's
okay yeah gonna be my daughter saw it
and she my daughter's old eight and she
goes salt like me on this catwalk 500
feet in the air with like [ __ ] eight
black dudes and she's like is that the
wu-tang clan and I'm signal earth no um
so uh how do we how do we wrap this up
why don't we put a bow on this here's
the deal you know that's a girl will do
a bus tour I will do a bus tour what do
you mean let's do it okay I mean I'm not
opposed to it let's do it i got the
city's mapped out ready tampa orlando
Atlanta Nashville Indy uh you know it's
funny what these are all places I've
been that no one came to see me sir I
mean yes remember again San Francisco DC
New York LA Boston like Seattle see
that's why you're you you just didn't do
the road like I did just spent 15 years
in those cities yeah these are all
cities i draw in go from from indy to
Columbus Columbus to dayton
in the Pittsburgh Pittsburgh to Philly
Philly to New York New York to DC and we
end in DC yeah to the only place people
come see me as d say I'm sorry New York
and DC yeah indeed it's like I can't
it's not Jesus like the charisma thing
it's like DC we could do a theater i
sell i could do a theater in DC now for
the first time probably i've been
selling out DC for like five [ __ ]
years yeah so that's my biggest market
anywhere cuz le in the morning I love
that game he's the best yeah he's a
grace I was one of them come on my
podcast DC's were kicking off so the
thing about Elliott is like he knows
[ __ ] about you that's really cool he's
I'm gonna I'm gonna suck his dick for a
second he's the best interviewer out
there yeah he does research you didn't
expect him to do yeah and he [ __ ]
loves laughs and he loves comedy for the
right reason he's not like he's just
yeah he said I love doing i getcha it'd
be great well do it what we'll do is
we'll do uh remember i bet we could
[ __ ] seguros the one that could
really spearhead this because he knows
about [ __ ] small venues yeah we could
do off nights and comedy clubs every
single [ __ ] night yeah we're never
gonna make our money there we need to do
a couple theaters on the way all right
I'm not opposed to them I'm in we're
gonna hang out the store tomorrow night
oh yeah that's right yeah I get will
[ __ ] put some nails in this get bill
to give us what we'll do is get bill to
get a tour bus and get it for a long
period time we'll just borrow for two
weeks let's get Ralphie tour bus yeah
I'm sure he'll he'll uh he'll give us
his bus what do you want to promote the
champs uh yeah I don't I mean whatever
just follow me on Twitter there's [ __ ]
on there that I i'll keep you abreast of
my [ __ ] I appreciate you doing this deal
oh yeah dude I'm i like you Bert so
tonight it was fun to come this what's
funny is like I just did a thing with
Schumer for like a promo for a movie
yeah then I directed it's like I
wouldn't see or otherwise unless we did
something together like like cuz she's
busy I'm busy so it's fun to get
together for [ __ ] like this yeah
podcaster make make I've gotten to hang
out with a lot more people like I would
have never hung out with Felipe yeah and
a percent and now I'm going and now now
we're hanging out a lot like I'm going
over to hang out them tonight yeah and
then I'll see you tomorrow life's great
to lease is awesome yeah
she is she was great she was like be I'm
excited man would thank you good oh come
on not my husband I appreciate it
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you